when i say like i was going to be top
biller i was going to build a million
like 2019 i said to the guys i'm going
to be a million this year and they're
like no you're not like crazy it's great
i had complete belief i knew i was going
to do it how do you think people can
cultivate more self-confidence and
self-belief do you think self-confidence
i wish i knew i'm not a confident person
i doubt myself a lot really and i think
that is probably what drives me on
because i don't know how i'm doing what
i'm doing like i like i wish i could
like give a blueprint to our current
team like guys this is exactly what to
do it's exactly what to say but i think
it's that fear of this could stop at any
moment yeah i'm not going to let it like
i'm not going to take my foot off the
gas it's the momentum that's got me here
and i'm going to keep on like i could
probably i've taken like 10 holidays in
my entire career like from back at the
golf course
all the way to this date now yeah i've
never i've never stopped the recruitment
mentors podcast is proudly sponsored by
vincerie and the award-winning sauce
breaker